[Music]
Kim Kardashian will go the extra mile to
pull off an epic fashion moment but
walking that mile
well it might take her a minute yep
Kim's not so stylish Shuffle comes on
the heels of a major career moment for
the star a collab with Dolce and Gabbana
at Milan Fashion Week Kim hit the runway
rocking a stunning black number as her
momager Kris Jenner and sister Chloe sat
in the front row but it was the look she
dawned to the after party that brought
the LOLs
yeah Kim shared a behind the scenes look
at that floor-length fitted silver
number complete with lace-up detailing
and let's just say it wasn't the most
practical choice
let's hear it for Kim's assistant turned
friend Steph Shepherd for documenting
the struggle so Kim could gift us with
that legendary Montage I don't know how
you're gonna top that listen Kim makes a
bunny hop up the stairs a shuffle across
the floor and a slide into the back seat
of a car look Flawless you just gotta
roll with it and now that I think about
it the whole thing is giving off major
Kendall Jenner Vibes yeah remember when
Kylie Jenner trolls Kenny back in July
posting this clip of the model as she
tried to walk up the stairs at Courtney
and Travis Barker's Italian wedding
venue
these stairs are crazy but back to Kim
[Music]
this isn't the first time this game's
founder has gone the distance in the
name of fashion it's always so much fun
back in May Kim turned heads at the Met
Gala in NYC sporting the legendary dress
Marilyn Monroe wore during her happy
Birthday Mr President performance this
is Marilyn Monroe's dress and it's 60
years old and she wore this when she
sang Happy Birthday to President John F
Kennedy in 1962. I had this idea to to
put it on and try it on and then
they came with like armed guards and
gloves and I tried it on it didn't fit
me and so I looked at them and I said
give me like three weeks and I I had to
lose 16 pounds down today to to be able
to fit this but I it was such a
challenge it was like a roll right I was
just getting permanent and during a
fitting for the Met Gala in 2019 Kim
admitted she was willing to wet her
pants in the name of fashion I gotta pee
it's a problem if I if it's an emergency
I think I peed my pants and then have my
sister wipe my leg up
this Theory I'm not even joking she can
wipe my leg up that was very hard to
breathe in and I'm not promoting
not sitting and not eating and not
peeing and not moving
um that was definitely a once like
once in a lifetime situation whether
she's wearing a piece of history or a
dress so tight she has to hop around all
night Kim always looks 10 out of 10 Fab
foreign